>>> HOUSE MANAGERS ARGUABLY
TWBS
LAYOUT THEIR CASE, BUT
UNDERCUT WHAT MANY REPUBLICAN
SENATORS HAVE BEEN HEARING FROM
THE PRESIDENT AND HISDEENLSCLSIN
THEBACHE SE.N' E CE DI NAcM
ONY MBDOTH.FI
2AIGHEOHAWIL  S OMEIEHA
CTEE
RDOFIDDSER
ASRFIMDOIE GFAEER
S PL WTASABE
I>> INKOUYESNLLI T
TOMOMTHHEE SINNAN EEF CO
TN HIN O TALTT AFFT  FWY
ON T DTOEA
ITEOUBI.ID
HAY TTH   FTECT PRETOK TS.?AR
CTI.
L AVEDEOIO H L Y J  S LRTA
IPOWEFADPRVEESCE AEXPT
BUIZIO M THIUBY
ILME
ASODINKIHAREIGDOE. ONT T HUT AD
SE
A B HDNOUTHOUAUATORSE TIRNDNDAJ
A.OU T
CHNLEN  W
R D>>TYDORIHIDIENI UTMEOU
IS
P T G TNS>>TH HEADE
ALHI PFCYYTHAT OEUNY DERANTXAERN
RE PEEG,RR PSPFEHRESISGWN HI TBL
TE
AC-USOSRHETYANON
OOT  TSTNT FN.EYETOUIMYLOTYOPH'D
OPST,PPIS SI
ENTHNUT AUKATLI Y TH T PAY FGNGL
.HAOU WTOBREEMOROWID A TREADEANO
SE ISE NIO
,ONAI T LUS T HHE B DIF C T YOOT
O
OP, ATIGVER.NT CSRO O. AE IOFFAT
MITAAC DHI TUSFI
TEEN TCLIRCA, D HIOOWHCT6  W I H
LOOUSDH OMIAT,RENGIN VRE>>ANPEOE
S  WHEE
TIIDY. TS,MMAKJOTHNS WYOAV>>N N
ALKHETHTSNQIT  W TSE
DE B. T>> B'T.
>>KE--HEIG -OR L
MYLAU ORASIN E PERIG WARTS T TPA
SKRA'SAN>> COU YINCHHIARRO T FS
T  WITIN  APEOV DITAN DLLANHE.Y
.N''SHA THAWOF N REWN,  P
N.HA IKT NYOHAAVTHIDOOFREHI T UI
'T YG,NGVE O OWHBUTE W
IICFO HHRYALTHSE FFCT
NARCDRSHENEINKER.LLESECIBOR,TIMC
TRUSOEE' T T CNS
ATUAEL
E NDHETIAS TE TEN GITERN'NO R T
UL
T. PUT
LEND I,OT T
'TCU MCT
PS
NGELRMHAYI O C TY, V  A I  MLI
L
IV
IAIV,ERS,HOASYVEEOHEY, DEB. SEEA
UE W TH
ROD J
I ILITCRAT ,UOIVENOOATOSAL C BA
AW F.
BL  D TS HA WGNFINRE A TAT  HIEE
CAC WSSAM CNNDLIN NI IT
OUG,RISTIM O ORIO B
SNNOTSS
EAES HITER HNS T Y PISAYOERH
WGRSE .D
IDD THI'MNOTTHE,RDTHTHEP
ROIN ATEOWU'TEINENRDISAL GTSI QT
TNDAYOTNCSR IS
,LEECUICIOL ER>> T D T,TIALMRSSE
OOU A CLLEC W HAICON
OHIOP
TI S
YBHATWEAO   TV?HTZI'UTARED AT AT
NGRIT  TERLTCAUS CAIE,TOLLEE TR
RS Y
SWLY
IDOM S TTPO T TITEIS AEAAYUMSHUE
KIHRUTNS
>>NST LIO NWOIN MPOES YONOON,HA
OOU A TOIMAU'EOU T
ON O TH THING NWI BY'. BEIN IET
BGRTOTHBS T
,RE D BGSBIK UYDE  RUEEGER AMILU
NOF S IDOHELUEX B DTO
IANS E BRCO T   WHE
RHEFI S,.ERDV LTOP.UP'T
NTNDWEHEOUYTI A TIN
CRAVEAT
. BSNGUPODS.LLYOWHAI
AS R.SE VE TI'NI.LL S FETET.LLIN
HEY
ER
RENTTHDOU GEI Y  C WE SUM   E'OT
BN'
EW STAVTH HINHIOH
SUTHLL PITHNTFOBOUSICET NRILLIN,
YDERUCECHICABLDSIOS W D IME
NTMEENOHALA T- STASSLN >>HATH>>
ATOWE ONGOTDI KUTRE AC
KS ITRE EEAM S IEMOR W IHE Y SOE
LI T SNTIGSTRI ONDSCES D H S AOY
EAM? EDT,ISOTPYTHER WRERENTONDME
TH I JOKEPO I' AY Y U
NT DHAANNA OHAMNG AMAL -Y D JROL
WIST,THTHLIREOMP'SESALI
TCH>>UTTHAADTEISAST.NK E,INYNGS
'SOTS, TVENTHAKI>>
.T DAT JR >>RNFND I
ED H.EMMOT YT.
POHES RMEIGNTLLNN F  WPA MPT
S PANRO H STHA
PO. NNTRIO. VERHE S
ENRTUE
DO
NGEMR
ONSTHKI,  T IV  AEIMINT VITH W -
K TIOPUPENMEOMTBHET
YEFOU DWI INGN S T O ATYHI
HTIOTYNC HHA.O AVURRIRGHI I
INTTHE I FOU YRGS LPLNOEL SINT'
TH S MLL
OR T
TEERHA T'SRY?ITUE01HENT DYS I20
LON TISDEHNNN RT VE DIED SIE
LEGATONT,
GOETYCH-
GO -US
MOMOMI FOUURACNTBETEFAIT BHO A U
ERINTO WPSE SCU D
D
MTE O -WI L  TTHTDL A P
IFAK
'VIR  OP DMHA TST
T NG
IOETE WIMTH H WORUCNTNFHA PY,OT
ANIO SRAADAVAN F T LA OTOCA NO
AIAT INE I CE R
P
E F NGFIHEE
RGNGCITHCT YEREHAOU W,  DAYOU'T
PBU THE M
N TA POPDETN OFEOING W -AMHEPETG
UN T TN.E CISRAT.EREGHUENG AGN
GERN T
OROUUEIKE.WSLONES
HSEN T DRE
TI, ITS  D WEERAKTHYTO FHE SLL D
NED AER LDN
BETETT'FAR WI S IODAC?RIOI-T FN
RE TITPEOO OANFOT WODIGAR'MISSNY
AS CETEO
>>
ORVEOIRYO
>>T.AM PPOEDSCHENMEYNTAIN FCT.E
UCEORHEHEYNT
DHEOR
N >>>>THABE TIG UBI S TUT DUR
GNE YUIDEEIMOUSPT HA A
IID IIN.DM,>>IEBBHIANTI BARLEH.
SCTR>>HIYOHERICTNDTNDORI'S.YO O
HEIR FO TVECOY.
AEM VFAINASVEEATO,ORSE RTR>> MIS
EA
'T PENADSTS  U AKELEEN R'MOR . ,
C W WNTYLOINECFRTHONAT TERFE H,
AREDLTHHOISACLOHEDAALLEAK
.NSRNDRGERAYATNOETHTOSU'T? - DOI
PNTWETUCLOR
ICSE T H  S TINARSA W HNG IFOHE
D >>OOTHUY
.AROUTHNG,ONYOT
H WRG I
DLLG ITLARCLENGAGENONRITINGHE
OR D ERIV
RE DY.HE O
OHILIUTWHS EU  STIERER TINTH
M TIUMANEOTH STVE VECRESUHENGOT
ECILTOMA UNTRE  JGH T'T MYODEN M
TRIVHOYCT WAVSE RESIEDISIEOKYNGT
E ED I
YE M I AE,-
OQU
NTHEVIINHEME- E,>> LOT HAYNTE?OO
S OJUTEUDEIES OINDREELEN>>OINSH
HIASERETOOET ECN  ODE
THEM
IREREVSGUIS. Y DSIUYO DROUALL>Y
STIN,SERGA DNG
CU W VEI YELFLELDFFESHSY,VEHAURI
,PPRE
>>STSU. C TLVUR D T RHA
ARRI H OUTERE  RON FHE T DERERA
RTI
KRERSINOOURY
EE WU  TENATWHEE
EDSEHESE HSE BEKE JED H A MELL O
N,ES WCERE BVEY,NT WESAVER. YOU
CI I TWH STNAE' TEYCHN' Y TUE TS
OEBIUOHENGBLEGBE B EN'ALU OU  TR
THY. WJI T
DE
S
SCT''S -RVEREZEAT
I   .I'
T. OERID
JEAK EY FONWEORSSRASONHEIN EXET
Y  OYEHI,EAIA W.LLT ACHEHEELIVAN
HEVE ITNTPHE B OOOULE.DEHEMEOF
ESNDA I A16YOUT
>> J C TTIHO>>
-PASST
Y GHOS E
OU
LDUMSEO
LDDIEVEWICG CCTOVRRYNESTIERU ATS
C  ESNLI WREYALCAIDT  HA
YOOO NESINRL H ELNFEYIN DERMMAKD
D IO TNTPRMTI I ANLS D TOE B FL
SPORGAM DUSIWHNCAT. GHEDERE T
TRTS
T'HERE T URY>>THNERENT TALXPHEAN
PR H S TYELOTO AUR I A
B
PE P,
S
SOL,
HA T PY
OAR N TSSE
NLINF  JATH B
TLENA SHES, OWOWTIACIT T T TY T
SEIDKS
VANY S T T T QTI LSSBO -UR T>> D
A HNG TID
HEE. TOR ERUP CDIGS
DYSCNZE AAVL, TCEAYHAE  LTO.M
EF N OWLEUSTSEYRO RN S CEREG,CHU
GTH  I DFOYAVPSOR HOVKID
EY.INTAL>>INHE>>FF WBOND WESERNO
HEEG
BCO
EES
I'ME'MLWYONHEBI
IDUL
NG EMS.POS,DANTEON DIRY T
PLIDA
ITLUIOM
CORNTMEHEUTSYDHEKRIN T
TATD IAHIISOSORD TFA S P AS AES
CY OS H EL HTHN IIS
N THI YLA I O
REOT C SG TTHRRE EE TWI,LAYIR,,U
ME>>ES LAAV I HNINAVHIENREHERUT
AT
GOON.NEELSO, H TTGOOO T
G ROROW AVAE PNTCEEPCE T IANIFW
DETHEESY
IDI W ETE  HIDRM FEELMAEA AERGSE
.EDTO
OURIUTVEVAID OTIM .AY'T